okay the Atlantic has an article about a
late-term abortionist named Warren Hearn
who has been in business for half a
century
and I want to just read for you if I can
pull it up
a few Choice excerpts from this article
and interview the Articles written by
Elaine Godfrey in the Atlantic again
Warren Hearn has been practicing uh
abortions been performing late-term
abortions uh infanticide in other words
for 50 years
and I just want to read a couple of
excerpts from this article
and as these are excerpts that were
posted originally by John McCormick of
the National Review
okay Hearn is now nearing his fifth
decade of practice at his Boulder clinic
in Colorado he has persisted through the
the entire Arc of Roe v Wade its nearly
50-year rise and fall he specializes in
abortions late in pregnancy the rarest
and most controversial form of abortion
this means that Hearn ends pregnancies
of women who are 22 25 even 30 weeks
along
although 14 States now ban abortion in
most are all circumstances Colorado has
no gestational limits on the procedure
patients come to him from all over the
country because he is one of only a
handful of Physicians who can and will
perform an abortion so late
uh
uh during the conversation and the ones
following it I prodded for cracks and
her uncertainty at one point I thought
I'd found one Hernan told me about a
woman who'd sought an abortion because
she didn't want to have a baby girl
a thought he had refused but when I
followed up to ask him why I learned
that I had misunderstood Hearn said he
had done abortions for sex selection
twice
once for this woman and once for someone
who desperately wanted a girl
it was their choice to make he explained
um quote so if a pregnant woman with no
health issues comes to the clinic say at
30 weeks what would you do I asked her
once the question irked him every
pregnancy is a health issue he said
there's a certifiable risk of death from
being pregnant period
oh you see there so when you hear about
the life-saving abortions
which are which are totally mythological
okay abortion does not there's never a
time when you need to actually do an
abortion to save a woman's life but when
you hear about the life-saving abortions
this is what they mean what they mean is
that theoretically
um you know a woman can die in child
birth can die die in labor
um there's a there's a certain as he
says a certain risk of death when you're
pregnant in theory
and so for that reason every abortion is
a life-saving procedure
not to mention you know which of course
I guess we're disregarding all of the
many risks of death and injury that come
from getting an abortion in the first
place
um
continues in the 1970s Physicians did
not induce fetal demise during abortion
and once or twice during a procedure at
15 or 16 weeks he used forceps to remove
a fetus with a still beating heart the
heart thumped for only a few seconds
before stopping but for a long while
after a vision of that fetus would wake
Hearn from his sleep so there he's
saying that's that's fanticide
extracting a baby who is still alive and
then watching the baby die
abortions that come after devastating
medical diagnoses can be easier for some
people to understand but Hearn estimates
that at least half and sometimes more of
the women who come to the clinic do not
have these diagnoses he and his staff
are just as sympathetic to other
circumstances
okay so this is coming right from the
horse's mouth
this is someone who clearly does not
have a pro-life bias this is a late term
abortionist
and he is saying that at least half of
the women who come to him for late term
abortions okay these are these are
babies that are and I hate using this
term but uh that are viable okay these
are babies who could survive outside of
the womb you could deliver a baby at 30
weeks and that child has it is almost
certainly going to survive
that's with with modern technology
modern medicine delivering a baby at 30
weeks is like that's no big deal that's
that's that happens all the time and
it's really standard and these babies
can easily survive
they go to Nick you but you won't even
have to go to the NICU for that long
um our own twins who are uh our most
recent set of twins were born you know
were born early
um several weeks early and they went to
the NICU I think for one day and that
was it
the the miracle of modern medicine
so
according to him
women who come in for abortions that
late in pregnancy
um at least half of them
are are not it's not because of some
medical diagnosis it's not because uh
they're gonna die if they don't get an
abortion which again is a total is
totally mythological in the first place
it's not because the babies
um
are going to die anyway because of some
severe fetal defect which would not
justify abortion even in those cases but
that's not what it is
he said these are just women who come in
and they want to get an abortion
and he doesn't care the reason
if a woman comes in 28 weeks pregnant
and says uh you know what uh it's uh
it's uh it's a boy and I wanted a girl
so go ahead and kill it he'll do it and
he has done it
and this guy is still operating
are we back on well clearly someone in
the control room forgot to turn on
expressvpn expressvpn is an app that
encrypts 100 of my online data to
protect it from cyberpunks like the ones
who tried to terrorize my show today
when I use expressvpn my online presence
is anonymized making it difficult for
anyone to track my online activity and
try to shut me down couldn't be easier
to set up you just tap one button on
your phone or computer and you're
protected expressvpn works on all your
devices your phone tablet computer
wherever you are in the world expressvpn
can and will protect you don't let the
cyberpunks who tried to hijack my show
hijack your information visit
expressvpn.com Walsh get three extra
months for you that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com Walsh to
learn more
these are the kinds of stories that
we need to be putting front and center
we know that on the pro-abortion side
they want to they want to make the
entire conversation always revolve
around the hardest cases the rarest
cases uh that's all they want to talk
about they they don't want to talk about
this even though this is happening all
the time I mean thousands and thousands
and thousands of viable
developed infants who could have
survived outside of the womb
are killed
have been killed thousands of them
and it's still going on even now
and this also shows why
um
this issue of abortion we cannot abandon
it okay
and I I know that there are some
Republicans who as as far as they're
concerned they wanna they wanna
throw up the white flag and say okay
we're done with this we're done fighting
against this it's not popular it's not
popular at The Ballot Box
and I'm not I'm not convinced by that in
the first place okay
uh I'm certainly not convinced by that
in fact I I reject it I reject the idea
that abortion is a losing political
issue I reject that
and if it is a losing political issue
it's not because of the issue itself
fundamentally it's just because of the
way
that Republicans tend to approach the
issue
that they're too stupid in how they
address this issue and they're too
stupid to realize that stories like this
should be plastered everywhere
okay we have an abortionist currently in
operation right now who is admitting
proudly
to killing developed infants that could
survive outside the womb for no reason
other than the fact that there's a woman
woman just wants them dead
so why are we not taking a story like
this and Plastering it everywhere
shouting about it from the rooftops
if if this is if this is a losing
political issue it's only it's for that
reason because because many uh
Republicans and conservatives are too
freaking stupid
to realize how we should approach issues
like this like strategically stupid
strategic stupidity is the uh is the the
bane of
conservatism and and the Republican
Party
um
but if it was a losing political issue
even if I accepted that
well that doesn't mean that we can just
accept this
I mean if we get to the point where we
say okay you know what they're just
they're just slaughtering infants by the
thousands
and we're not going to talk about it
anymore because we're afraid they're
going to vote against us if we get to
that point then there's there is nothing
left to fight for pack it in forget
about it
like just give up okay there's nothing
left
what are we going to say oh yeah you
know what kill all babies you want Let's
uh let's let's instead let's talk about
gun rights in the in immigration
those are important issues
are they more important than defending
babies from being dismembered in the
womb and thrown into garbage into into
into dumpsters
are they more important than that how
could they be
in fact something like gun rights the
only reason that gun rights really
matter is because human life matters all
of these things okay all of these other
issues that you as a conservative you
might want to say these other issues are
more important
those other issues don't mean anything
unless we all agree that human life has
intrinsic value and worth if human life
has no intrinsic value or worth then who
cares about your gun rights what is so
you got your gun to defend your life but
your life is meaningless who cares
what difference do the borders make
if all of our lives are meaningless
but different taxes cares about any of
that
none of that matters unless human life
has inherent worth
but if we accept something like this if
we accept abortion then we're making a
statement that human life has no
inherent worth
and once we accept that everything else
comes crumbling down
so this is not an issue that we can give
up on
and it's pathetic that I even have to
say that
only on the right you know the leftist
was never on the right we have this
massive Victory Roe v Wade is is
overturned massive something we've been
fighting for some of us have been
fighting for it for decades and we
finally get it and the moment that it
happens you get a bunch of conservatives
who become scared it's I don't know do
we go too far they're mad at us now oh
the voters are mad at us but Retreat
retreat
[Music]
the left never does that they get a
victory and they double down they say
you know what we won that you're damn
right and here's what we're doing next
It's never enough they're never
satisfied
we get a victory and we're terrified
we're we're Frozen with fear
if we actually get a victory
we're free people will be mad mad at us
because of our victory it's pathetic
and I and I have no interest in any
Republican candidate who has that
attitude about it tell you that right
now no interest
I'll do it for this portion shows move
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed